chez alexandre loukachenko mesdames
messieurs
nous vous informons brièvement des
résultats de notre discussion
aujourd'hui avec le président biélorusse
comme toujours elles ont été très dense
et constructive et ça correspond
parfaitement au caractère des relations
entre nos deux pays j'ai dit plusieurs
fois que la biélorussie est un bon
voisin est un partenaire très prochaine
la construction l'accord la
collaboration entre nos deux pays se
fait sur la base d'une de la prise en
compte des intérêts mutuels et dans le
respect plein de la russie et de la
biélorussie nous avons une histoire
commune des valeurs spirituelles en
commun et donc ce sont des liens de
parenté mais nous avons un partenariat
économique important au sein de la cbi
et
en 2020 il aura été à la troisième
position
cette année le volume des échanges a
retrouvé le niveau d'avant la pandémie
et miss 17
milliards de dollars avec une
augmentation de 35%
la russie représente 50% du commerce
extérieur de la biélorussie ce qui veut
dire que les investissements sont très
importants et ce n'est pas par hasard
que les discussions aujourd'hui
portaient essentiellement sur la
composante d'investissement dans nos
relations et aussi sur le plan de
l'intégration dans le cadre de l'état de
l'union comme vous le savez les
gouvernements des deux pays depuis
plusieurs années nous avons compte
aujourd'hui que
ce travail était lancée il ya trois ou
quatre ans
donc depuis quelques années
nous travaillons sur un certain nombre
de documents visant à favoriser ce
processus d'intégration il s'agit de 28
programmes de
d'union en matière d'unification des
législations entre nos deux pays
appliqué à l'économie et qui porte sur
les activités des entités des deux pays
dans le domaine du marché énergétique du
marché du marché des transports
et la réalisation d'un certain nombre de
points de la politique industrielle et
agricole et je tiens à souligner que les
28 programmes ont été signés aujourd'hui
ont été validées par
là le conseil des ministres de l'état de
l'union à minsk
et donc
la prochaine séance devrait se tenir
avant la fin de l'année on va voir nos
plannings pour valider une date
donc de mots aussi sur la teneur de ces
programmes une partie d'entre eux et
vise l'unification en matière
fiscale avec des principes communs de
d'imposition et de gestion
administrative des impôts qui se
présentent en commun entre les deux
états
il ya aussi la structure des prix les
produits et aussi la mise en phase d de
la politique de crédit avec une
régulation monétaire et une
harmonisation des systèmes de paiement
dans le cadre de l'état de l'union tout
cela permettra d'assurer une concurrence
saine et de renforcer l'activité sur les
marchés financiers et de réagir
efficacement face aux menaces de
d'activités criminelles soit le
financement du terrorisme soient là les
trafics financiers
nous travaillons aussi sur
l'harmonisation des prises sur le marché
de l'énergie de façon à trouver des
approches compréhensible pour les deux
le prix pour
le
le prix du gaz pour la biélorussie sera
maintenue en 2022 et le 1er décembre
2023 un document sera signé pour
l'unification du marché du gaz dans le
cadre de l'état de nous nous prévoyons
également une unification des marchés
pétroliers et des produits hydrocarbures
cela concerne aussi le marché
d'électricité dans le cadre de ses
programmes de l'état de l'union
et il y aura aussi un un effort
d'harmonisation sur le plan de la
législation sur les z et assurances
sociales pour la pour les retraites pour
les aides aux enfants pour l'emploi et
tout cela est important pour la mise en
place d'un espace économique et
commercial entre nos deux pays comme
cela était prévu
dans le traité de 2019
cela donne un coup de pouce important
pour les relations économiques entre nos
deux pays
cela vise aussi une amélioration de la
productivité
et cela concerne bien évidemment
l'activité des pme avec la création
d'emplois les milieux d'affaires
russo et bien sûr biélorusse permettront
de bénéficier pourront bénéficier de
soutien avec la mise en place de
nouvelles entreprises notamment sur le
plan de l'export ce qui est plus
important encore c'est que ce processus
d'intégration qui doit être bénéfique
pour les simples pour les citoyens
ordinaires dans deux pays dans une
égalité de droits sur le plan politique
comme sur le plan social et ce qui est
important c'est que les conditions
d'amélioration de
vie soient réunies nous avons parlé
aussi des questions de construction d'un
espace de défense ont en commun est
d'assurer la sécurité de l'état d'union
dans son périmètre extérieur une grande
attente attention a été accordée aussi
aux manoeuvres militaires qui vont avoir
lieu bientôt zapad
ces
manoeuvres ne sont pas dirigées contre
qui que ce soit mais elles sont logiques
dans ce travail de défense
notamment dans le cadre de
l'augmentation du potentiel militaire
aux frontières d'un autre état de
l'union
monsieur loukachenko a parlé de la
situation en intérieur
dans son pays qui s'est nettement
stabilisées pour conclure je voudrais
dire aussi que cette coopération
mutuellement avantage de moeurs
1 une orientation stratégique une
priorité pour nos deux états et je tiens
à manifester ma reconnaissance au
gouvernement et aux services de l'état
et aux équipes d'experts qui ont
participé à l'élaboration du programme
de l'état de l'union
et je m'adresse maintenant à mes
collègues des services de l'état je vous
remercie pour les efforts que vous avez
fait pour parvenir à des résultats
concrets et nous partons du principe que
encore une fois je m'exprime aux membres
du gouvernement je vous demande de
continuer à travailler dans cet esprit
je vous remercie pour votre attention
chers l'admirent ladmirault itx
distinguer représentants des mass médias
en vertu la tradition du protocole je
voudrais je tiens à remercier
le président la russie pour l'accueil
qui nous a été réservé à nous à tout
notre délégation et le remercier pour
une pour une discussion franche entière
et constructive de notre entretien je
en outre vous tous aujourd'hui nous
autres nous autres journalistes
vous avez maintenant la possibilité
d'entendre la première bouche dans la
bouche main les résultats de cette
rencontre nous nous avons pas agathe et
il faut bien le reconnaître
lors de telles rencontres
à l'issue de nauzan longues négociations
je commencerai par le thème le plus
important car le plus d'ampleur est le
plus débattu c'est le destin le sort des
programmes de dette
l'état fédéral et a dit fier je serai de
compléter ce qui a été dit par le
président russe je m'excusais que je
mens commencerait par l'histoire de la
question
le président vient de dire que ce
travail a débuté il y a trois ans
et nous avons réagi aux remarques vos
prétentions à la critique qui est fait
aux reproches
six ans belle russie que sept états
fédérés qui a perdu son rythme qui est
en train de perdre des vitesses main un
travail plus concret sur les feux de
route qui a vraiment démarré il y a plus
de trois ans
ces cartes qui représente en fait
des contours d'intégration par dom
imprécis dans deux feux de route c'était
des schémas d'une autre parcours à
suivre
en examinant tel ou tel un thématique
des relations d'état à état non nous
avons établi des schémas
donc aujourd'hui chacun des programmes
d'aujourd'hui et ses programmes qui sont
donnés ils sont devenus des programmes
il ya un an et demi quand nous avons
abordé d
approcher d
les accords plus concret il a fallu
réaliser des plats des plans concrets
pour répondre à la sollicitude de nos
[Musique]
citoyens dans l'impasse c'est que c'est
une réponse à des heures des accords en
plaidant que les gouvernements ont
accompli un travail que le seul nous
avons pris toutes les décisions de
principe qui nous concerne avec la
démission lundi proche couronne parrot
relater tout le contenu des documents
qui seront publiés s'est passé credoc
nozer je vais souliers ce qu'il a de
plus de licenciés tout d'abord les
droits égaux pour les agents économiques
de nos pays de l'ue russie de russie les
conditions ex-aequo où les représentants
de la belle russie coprésidents
belleruche vous le dire on parle depuis
plusieurs années
c'est le fondement de tout nous sommes
des partenaires égaux pour tous les
partenaires sur les marches de russes et
bélarusses il faut une concurrence
loyale et c'est au nom de cette égalité
en droit de gros opération mutuellement
enrichissante et une coopération c'est
pour cela qu'on a entamé cette oeuvre
d'intégration russo de russes il ya des
mécanismes de développement de l'espace
économique uni la formation des marchés
sectoriels unifiée l'harmonisation des
systèmes financiers fiscales monétaires
et commerciales
je tiens à noter en plus que la solution
des problèmes a notamment des matières
énergétiques livre à la bélarussie de
services de transport l'investissement
de nouveaux projets d'investissements
lama principaux dans la politique
agricole 1 le mam niveau de garantie
sociale pour nos citoyens au le
président russe vient d'en parler avec
le détail il est temps de demander à nos
critiques en bélarussie
précisément belle russie qui sont
nombreux il y a ceux qui résident encore
embelli aussi et d'autres canaux fui des
soi disant opposants car critiquant mois
mamane aux autorités disent est guéri je
voudrais bien leur demander ces
critiques de notre intégration en russie
je voudrais aussi m'enquérir auprès
d'écrire de nos critiques en russie où
vous voyez-vous un poids qui attaché au
pied de la fédération de aussi
aux rien aucun mal pour les peuples de
la russie des bleus aussi dans ses
programmes et
tous visent comme l'a dit le président
là aussi avec ressorts du bien-être de
leur population
il faut bien mettre un poing dans tous
ces discussions d'offres intégration
revêtent un caractère
exceptionnellement en mutuellement
avantageux et nous ont pu arriver à la
compréhension mutuelle surtout les dans
tous les domaines notre gouvernement
sans tarder va au profit de certains
projets déjà en
concéder me serais fait de la musique
cantona mettre la dernière main et là
nous sommes sûr on pourra approuver
après faire approuver ce parc et de
programmes à la
ce sont des cons c'est supérieur n'osais
pas nous allons essayer de définir la
date pour la tenue de ses côtés
supérieur on nous accuse souvent de cet
état les restes après il s'agit d'un
projet politique
c'est une union intégré qui est avancé
sur dans tout le domaine en politique
également c'est pas par exemple notre
alliance militaro politique pour lequel
le cachons pas dans bien de domaines
comme la politique extérieure la
politique de défense
la sécurité
nous avons pu avancer très loin elvis
est chargé de nous prouver que ce que
nous sommes en train de faire visent le
bien elle a besoin concret de nos
populations les bélarusses et russes ne
se sont pas étrangers à entre dans les
deux pays il peut se déplacer librement
faire des études travaillait avoir des
emplois c'est quelque chose qui revient
cher ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est un de ceux dont il
n'a jamais été comme cela un toujours ce
la meilleure preuve de la viabilité de
notre union je suis absolument convaincu
que l'approfondissement de l'intégration
la croissance de notre coopération sur
le meilleur indicateur 1 ghz réponse à
tous ceux que nous soit dit mal ensemble
nous serons plus forts
et au début de nos entretiens le
président devrait aussi a dit une chose
très importante intéressante
nous sortons d'une situation
d'un monde a affolé de la par la
pandémie ou durant cette période les
volumes de production et bien d'autres
processus
sont en chute et il nous faut trouver
des stimulus supplémentaire pour
développer la vie socio économique dans
le pays et sociétés
bien raison c'est exact nous sommes dans
cette alliance de deux pays de deux
états nous cherchons des réponses pour
nous avons discuté également des
promenades internationaux nos relations
avec nos voisins des pays des
groupements sommes arrêtés ont déteint
sur le situation dans les zones
d'instabilité sud en afghanistan du
point de vue des menaces pour la
sécurité nationale de cet état unifié
federec de l'ancienne russie dans ce
contexte faudra assurer la sécurité
globale de nos pays et de laisser dans
son ensemble
notre unité qui sera confirmé un leurre
d'essence à douchapt dans la vie de
douche hammam au sort de l'europe nous
abel russie qui sont loin du théâtre des
opérations
nous avons ressentir les contrecoups de
la crise afghane ce qui se passe le
problème des religions en offre tiers
comment se comporte le soin lisa
occident progressiste qui agite qui veut
avec le clic kills et arnaud aborde les
problèmes des exercices
whaou est un 20 à 25 pour répondre aux
menaces que nous allons doc résistent à
ces menaces faire face à ces menaces il
faut pas protesté décrié
c'est de ces exercices militaires nous
avons une armée commune un groupe un
combat qu'il faudra former au niveau
militaire nous faisons rien de
particulier ria que ne fasse nos rivaux
et et nos adversaires
ceux ci gît d'une normalisation continue
des transports de la coopération dans le
domaine de la microélectronique et dans
la sphère du bâtiment
nous sommes sûrs que la pratique de
l'utilisation potentielle certificat de
production de voix devrait être à
énergie tout l'est ne n'ont pas été
dénouée dans notre coopération ce qui
est normal mais la plateforme pour un
mouvement de l'avant a été existe déjà
au rendez vous donc nous allons offrir
des garanties sociales et art que le
bien-être des russes des blouses des
russes livre alice beaucoup on pourrait
croire que non négocié nos pourparlers
de programa fédéraux sont trop tu es tu
allé dans le temps et
qu'elle ne tombe pas à sont pas trop
attentive à ces problèmes il pourrait
pas en être autrement parce que je me
souviens que vers le milieu ou la fin
des années 90 que nous avons échangé nos
lettres de créance sur cette union entre
deux états nous avons ont ils
atteignaient de vitesse de l'intégration
entre les reussilles ed weiler russie et
à l'époque l'union douanière le racisme
qui a été créé sur votre initiative
et ils s'attirent très présente et de la
série a c'est trois niveaux
sur l'espace politique les vitesses
peuvent varier mais nous avons toujours
pu aller nous avons devancé tout le
monde suit elle si peut-être pour
renoncer à cet état de l'union
en tant d importer cette portée à lui un
reset il nous aurait assez
d'intelligence ne pas le faire
le nouveau président la russie l'a
soutenue cette année nous sommes pas
trompés nous donnons l'exemple de la
manière dont ils fois à les avoir c'est
vers
l'union
eurasiatique me sens comme un bulldozer
qui
dégagent la route pour le future union
fédéraux sur l'espace postsoviétique
l'union soit un exemple c'est une voie
qu'il faudra suivre
ces états qui compteront sur une union
plus étroite
avec tous ces délicatesses le président
n'a pas mentionné que quelques va
absorber qu'elle aime dévorer quelqu'un
d'autre nous n'avons jamais un souffert
de cette maladie si qu'ici les eu et on
est malade on pourra les guérir
je viens de dire nous sommes
suffisamment intelligents à saint-élie
jandaud si nous avons besoin d'avoir des
relations vraies vraiment encore plus
serré encore plus puissant que dans un
était fait des faits nous allons le
faire d'une manière élémentaire donc
n'essayez pas d'agiter des anciennes à
d'anciennes phrase terme cocon envie de
le dévorer quelques d'autres que nous le
faisons aux dépens du peuple
il y avait huit orienté sur programme
que nous avons eu nous faudra remplir en
toisant peut-être mais c'est très peu
dans l'histoire de deux pays d'auge il
faut pas trop souffrir je vous fais tout
le possible qui est dans l'intérêt du
peuple et si nous avons besoin
d'une meilleure orientation militaire
politique intégrée ce que nous allons le
faire rapidement mentalement dès que
nous sentons couleurs que cela est
requis par le peuple en russie rebelles
russie
l'important aujourd'hui nous en avons
parlé avec les outils nous avons aussi
10,28 programme
il s'agit de regards conceptuelle sur
tel ou tel problème
aujourd'hui il faudra
pour compulser toutes nos législations
internes que nous allons adore adopté
que nous allons adapter pardon et que
nous allons mettre sur lire dans la voix
qui est définie par mois et le président
russe et que nous ferons confirmée par
dans notre grosse supérieur d'état je
vous remercie
deux questions pour les journalistes de
russie et de villerupt si nous
commencions par nos invités
donc on fait un moment à l'accord
donc vladimir matthiew de lagence
d'information belleton
une question
dans la liste des questions
entrant dans les programmes il s'agit de
l'intégration entre nos deux états au
plus haut niveau
il faut rendre hommage au gouvernement
qui a su se mettre d'accord sur un
certain nombre de questions qui sont
délicates et c'est juste de la politique
monétaire la politique de crédit un
certain nombre de problèmes sectoriels
les garanties sociales
mais il faut reconnaître aussi que
depuis un certain nombre d'années
chaque année de plus en plus
un certain nombre de problèmes
d'ordre économique et commerciale se
sont maintenues
et de la part de la biélorussie
les certaines de ces questions n'ont pas
été respectées c'est par exemple les
conditions par exemple de chauffeurs
routiers biélorusse en russie sont plus
compliquées sont plus difficiles que
pour des conducteurs
lituaniens ou polonais est ce que les
programmes prévus permettrait de
repartir de zéro pour traiter ces
problèmes à l'avenir
donc vous avez regardé ça de façon un
peu superficielle ces questions
sur lesquelles nous avons eu du mal à
trouver des solutions et si on entre
dans les détails on comprend
pourquoi
nous avons mis tant de temps à parvenir
à cet accord
c'est parce que une partie
considéré que ça devait se
résoudre au niveau gouvernemental et
l'autre parti considéré que telle ou
telle solution ne pouvait pas être
prises tant qui avait pas de solution
plus général qui avait été prise
je le répète encore une fois cela revêt
un caractère essentiel
nous avons traité de questions
essentiellement macro économique je vais
pas entrer dans les détails vous
comprenez ce que je pense il s'agit d'
harmonisation de la politique de crédit
[Musique]
l'intégration des systèmes de paiement
d'accords sur
la sécurité sur le renforcement de la
coopération en matière douanière et
fiscale
donc il s'agit de transparence des frais
douaniers
et
de la transparence de l'élaboration des
tarifs nos experts ont considéré que
sans résolution de ce problème on ne
pouvait pas passer à table ou tel groupe
de produits compris les produits
énergétiques ne nous sommes mis d'accord
pour mettre en place une méthodologie
ces importantes pour
harmoniser tous ces systèmes de façon à
ce que les organes les services publics
puissent contrôler tout cela c'est à
dire quand ton aura une transparence
totale sur ces questions tarifaires par
exemple entre la biélorussie la russie
et par exemple quand elle produit
vient par exemple sur le titre là aussi
ça permet de parler d'un de tarifs en
détail et cela nous permet aussi de
parler du passage à une
politique industrielle
notamment aux services en matière de
satisfaction des demandes de l'état
et là effectivement on peut
envisager d'un point de vue critique ces
politiques mais je dirais que nous avons
un autre parcours a été long parce que
les discussions avec la partie d'une rue
sont difficiles disons le met petit à
petit
petit à petit nous arrivons à aborder
deux points de vue concrète du plan d'un
point de vue concret toutes ces
questions qui se posent tous tous les
problèmes sont des primes de détail et
quand on parvient justement au niveau
des détails on met tout sur la table et
à ce moment là on peut réunir toutes les
pièces du puzzle et en espérant que ça
va marcher je remercie encore une petite
question puisque je cette possibilité
est ce que vous avez parlé des liaisons
aériennes
est ce qu elles ont été reprises
complètement après les restrictions
liées aux copies des scans décision qui
a été prise
non nous en avons parlé la fois
précédente cette fois ci cette question
n'a pas été soulevée par monsieur
lukashenko mai
mais si le cachet qu'on ne sait pas
encore quelle décision était prise au
niveau gouvernemental
ici nous avons décidé de supprimer
toutes les restrictions bâtir de laison
rien vous voulez vous ne me l'aviez pas
dit eh ben voilà je vous informais merci
donc
avant
la mise en place de ces restrictions
liées aux kovy
nous avions
200 un vol entre deux pays aujourd'hui
on en a 36
je pense pas qu'on puisse retrouver le
niveau d'avant qu'ovide en quelques
jours ça va pas se faire tout seul il
faut que le marché revienne à cet état
mais je pense que cette restauration à
se faire rapidement notamment
parce que notamment les accords dont
nous avons parlé justement vont se
mettre en place
un journaliste russe prend première
chaîne
bonjour une question pour les deux
présidents vous avez parlé de
l'intégration économique quelles sont
les perspectives de l'intégration
politique et est-ce qu'elle existe et
pour revenir sur les programmes de
l'état de l'union
est ce qu'il y aura des tarifs spéciaux
en matière énergétique pour la
biélorussie est ce qu'on peut mettre un
régulateur juridique unique pour les
deux pays est ce qu'il ya une décision
qui a été prise sur la question
monétaire vous avez parlé de soutien en
matière de crédit en ce qui concerne la
l'intégration politique
cela avait été posée dès le début
[Musique]
en 2007 2009 vous avions parlé de cela
et comme la pause et comme l'a dit votre
collègue à propos de certains groupes de
produits nous sommes parvenus à la
conclusion que il fallait répond
répondent non pas de façon sectorielle
mais de façon plus globale
pour avoir ainsi une base économique ce
stable et il faut en discuter souvent et
c'est pareil nous considérons que
malgré toute la noblesse de cette de ce
dessin il faut qu'ils aient une base un
fondement économique stable ici qui
puisse favoriser cette ce rapprochement
politique nous n'avons pas encore parlé
de tout ça encore une fois je le répète
c'est d'abord l'aspect économique et à
ce moment là
de façon naturelle des compléments
viendront peut-être un parlement
unitaire qui pourrait se faire mais tout
cela doit se nourrir avec le temps nous
n'avons pas parlé aujourd'hui et ce
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour la
deuxième partie de votre question c'est
est
est ce que roy des tarifs spéciaux pour
les produits énergétiques
élémentaire oui je les dis sur certains
groupes de produits nous aurons une
approche globale en ce qui concerne les
produits énergétiques c'est une question
délicate mais je les y ai nous
maintenons pour l'année prochaine le
tarif nous maintenons inchangé le tarif
qui est pratique et
donc jusqu'en 2022
le prix au mètre cube de 28 dollars
sachez que c'est
beaucoup moins cher que
que pour les tarifs de l'europe
c'est-à-dire sans indexer
pour la biélorussie au tarif en dollars
donc là c'est on a une augmentation des
prix de l'ordre de 5%
mais sens indexés sûr nous ne négocions
pas sur le dollar
dans pour l'année en cours et après je
le dis nous allons élaborer une approche
générale sur le marché du gaz et sur le
marché du pétrole et des produits
pétroliers et troisième aspect qu
un soutien crédits à risque oui les deux
états
je travaille là-dessus dès le volume
total des crédits en septembre
courant
pour la fin de l'année 2022 est de
630 millions de dollars si je me trompe
pas
oui peut-être 636 140 à peu près
donc c'est plus de 600 millions de
dollars
en ce qui concerne l'intégration
politique je souscris à l'opinion de
vladimir la dynamique là pas trop
modeste pour décrire son rôle dans le
règlement de ces questions à l'époque
nous avons buté contre certains
problèmes à caractère politique dans
notre union notamment le monsieur vous
dit vrai licha
cette phrase superbe
dans le bureau nous étions en tête à
tête puis nous étions à l'époque lui il
y avait plus de monde en reprochant aux
spécialistes qui travaillait
notamment
s'ils ne vont buter contre ce problème
qu'on peut pas rire là maintenant nous
allons peut-être le remettre à plus tard
jusqu'au moment nous où
ce problème viendra sa maturité depuis
nous n'avons pas voulu trop politisé de
nos négociations sur ce plan mais je
vous dis franchement ça en toute
sincérité quand nous aurons besoin nous
allons revenir sur n'importe quel
problème y compris politiques à
caractère politique et partir de là nous
allons construire nos rapports nous
n'allons pas tarder comme on dit
toujours en russie en mai de russie
l'important c'est que ce que ce soit le
peuple qui le désirent donc je me range
je souffrais la thèse du présidentielle
vous allez à l'intér présidentielle
quant aux prix spéciaux pour la belle
russe si vous devez savoir que nous
avons surtout les tous les biens nous
avons la spécificité des prix c'est
qu'au sein de notre union sans de
l'union eurasiatique
il y a il n'y a pas de droits de douane
à parfum certains à prélèvements
notamment sur les matières énergétiques
vous la dire mentionnait le gaz qui
lient à des déductions fermer tous les
ans nous sommes en train de corriger le
prix y compris le prix du gaz pour le
pétrole nous sommes au niveau du prix
mondial
continue
des droits aux de sortie si nous vendons
des produits
pétroliers à l'extérieur de la merci
quant au soutien en matière de crédit
mais ce petit la parole à dire la
sympathie mais je le dis je lui ai
demandé
nous n'avons pas de crédits
supplémentaires si cette centrale
nucléaire pour laquelle nous avons créé
10 la pratique la fédération russe si
nous arrivons faire des économies qui me
rend cette économiquement comme un
crédit on va rebondir oui nous allons
penser s'il ya de beaux projets pour
l'avenir c'est d'un récital me convient
parfaitement et ce crédit dont on vient
de parler mon homologue
en ce qui concerne la monnaie unique il
faut que vous en tant que journaliste
vous commencez pas que poutine ou le
cochon que sont en train de freiner ce
processus que nous avons étudié ce
problème à l'époque la barre centrale de
russie et notre banque nationale à la
main vous à l'unanimité nous ont demandé
de ne pas toucher à cette question
roulement ni eux ni nos pays ne sont pas
aniane inopinés n'y sont pas encore
après et nous avons donc remis ce
problème à plus tard besson nous allons
retourner
on y lira le dollar l'euro le double la
question toujours
il s'agit d'un centre d'émission unique
wallace et là le hic là on a des
problèmes mais je pense que mam de notre
vie nous allons régler ce problème de
notre vivant voilà ce que je voulais
ajouter période au lisseur des questions
pour la monnaie unique
nous sommes d'accord et avec un essor
grégory wisches d'accord que la même
politique macro économique les premiers
pas ôté franchi dans ce domaine que
laborde centrale la russie la banque
nationale bellouz doivent harmoniser
leurs politiques de crédit des systèmes
de paiement la politique need la
sécurité informationnelle dans la sphère
bancaire cède approche
d'un outil d'un outil sportif loup puis
c'est tout cela figure ces programmes
que nous allons signer donc là on verra
plus tard
maman en europe de l'union européenne
avec des pays économiquement plus faible
qui souffrent qui auraient pu y aura
bien un ami d'emma lui à leur bas il n'a
pas de monnaie nationale tandis que
l'euro est une monnaie solide quand il a
fait re super seulement deux mois
j'aurais des prix et ce qui est grandes
conséquences sociales
trop lourde il faut donc analyser les
avantages des inconvénients les aspects
positifs
et négatifs
négatif chez nos voisins
vous avez évoqué les prix des matières
énergétiques
je viens de dire que quand va-t-on aux
quotas sur le marché libre il ya 650
$ pour 1 milliard de mètres cubes sur
les aires d esprit intelligent de leurs
commissions que les prix de marché pour
le gasoil si le résultat nous avons une
autre approche on a aussi des prix de
marché là pour l'évaluation de frime ce
prix est attaché au prix du pétrole ce
le marché lui même qui sait qui se
charge de régler et les the cia sio sont
plus plus souple là ils ont déjà sur
certains produisant déjà coup il ya un
rétive à sion une flambée de l'activité
et puis le prix du gaz a commencé a
devancé le prix du pétrole des produits
pétroliers et pour les contrats à long
terme et pour notre principe de ne
comprends pas ce prix là et ceux qui
sont d'accord signé des contrats avec
nous des contrats long terme en europe
ils peuvent sans ils peuvent faire la
fête sinon ils auraient été obligés de
payer 650 et gaz pauvre à 220 dollars
pour le milieu de matricule pour le
maître queux pour le prix de pétrole se
seraient gazprom a intérêt à tout ça
tout cela parce que cela crée secret un
coussin de sécurité pour qu'elles
produisent rapporte pas de chute brutale
des prix voilà c'est dans l'intérêt de
tout le monde mais comme indien son
époque on a inventé des choses comme un
aveu commission à l'ats martin whalen le
résultat wuala voici le résultat tu l'a
voulu
georges za
aux adeptes du côté belle russe qui
contre eux qui continuent à l'exo
sur les migrants c'est la conséquence de
la situation que nous observons
afghanistan et la b la russie a été
touchée par cette crise et humanitaires
aux frontières de l'europe et à l'europe
en europe on ferme les yeux sur les
extensions des autorités polonaises à
l'égard des réfugiés cause des autres
pays au lieu d'aider il est aisé les
chasses de leur territoire sans
cérémonie sophie tiers en utilisant des
moyens spéciaux de police ce qu'elle
peut nous à voir avec les principes
démocratiques les droits de l'homme des
favoris de l'occident
selon la perdras prochainement d'être
d'atteindre as des actions aux communes
de bosco de misc pour régler ce problème
des migrants
vous avez
faites très intéressant à raconter
quant à l'action commune on m'appelle
ceux qui m'appellent ce sommet mes
collègues occidentaux
les deux leaders 0 de certains pays de
l'occident
en invoquant
cette crise
à la frontière de bello avait créé une
pologne la lituanie
je ne concernait pas ce sont par nos
frontières ce sont les frontières de la
république but de russie et de la
pologne de leurs de la lituanie est la
première question qui se pose là
tout le monde veut parler directement
aux talibans mam
6,6 et organise ce fait partie des
organisations terroristes par le i
indique talibans qui contrôlent tout le
territoire il faut lui parler
le président loukachenko
si la venue au pouvoir non pas grâce à
elle nous tard mais
il était élu le résultat peut déplaire
ça c'est une autre question
mais ma réponse est claire aller parler
aux autorités bélarusses
c'est pas à nous de poser cette question
la russie diapos ria
premières choses premièrement et
deuxièmement en effet on nous demande
d'aidé
faire
sortie à faire et je alex a fait
ressortir certains citoyens gars faut
pas d'une manière contre leur destine et
nous concertons les autorités talibane
nous sommes en train de faire le pays
d'europe nous disent qu'ils évoquent la
catastrophe qu'a lieu là bas il s'excuse
il
se fait d'avoir abandonné lors
les hommes ce parti d'avoir qui viennent
à la frontière afghano lituanie à nos
abonnés il n'a pas la grosse au clonage
ou dit manière lituaniens qui chassent
tout le monde et les avions compris je
ne comprends pas cette logique on peut
accuser la même logique de tous les
torts mais au moins vous ne voulez pas
séparer les afghans au moins de ces
migrants pourquoi on les chasse aux les
repousses ou en afghanistan suite on
nous demande de les exfiltrer par la
suite dans le mien aucune logique à cela
sans donner d'appréciation politique je
tiens à souligner une chose que la
russie n'y est pour rien c'est la faire
le show s'ouvre à deux labels russie est
de ses voisins est votre appréciation
personnelle
voyez vous que la baie de russie a
découvert une manière libre et contre
lesquels je ferai pas une déclaration
qui ne manque ce sont pas des
déclarations d'un second cinéma mon
collègue est un grand spécialiste de
grandes déclarations il pourra vous dire
des choses mais je peux le faire en
votre présence faire de déclarations
brutales
quelque part de guerre de guerre et
brident la réponse est claire
vous voulez quoi clarifier le problème
vous voulez vraiment résoudre ce
problème adressez vous aux autorités
bélarusses à n'importe quel niveau
saleh le résoudre avec l'état voisin
vous n'y sont pour rien
je vois dire la mire l'admirer ichat est
trop délicat je le connais bien je les
informe à ce sujet nous sommes nous en
avons parlé l'union européenne
[Musique]
et les autres essaient de résoudre ce
problème en faisant alors des
prétentions à la dire au gouvernement
russe à mon collègue essayé d'agir sur
luca chaque code vert pression sur lui
je suis reconnaissant pour cette de
cette position qu'il vient d'exprimer il
y à gouvernance belle russie il y a une
autorité allait les voir pour régler ce
problème là bas
refusent de parler de nous parler parce
que soi disant c'est quoi que le
président freddy pas légitime ou bien
le gouvernement départ a le talent
immense et autres choses par les hôtels
ipsos là ils peuvent parler et peuvent
reconstruire un dialogue établir un
dialogue avec les talibans
donc je remercie le russe pour cette
cette position c'est du position qui
trouve la compréhension chez moi et chez
les autres dirigeants européens de
l'emploi mais nous ont perdu de vue un
moment peut-être les journalistes russes
bélarusses le savent bien
dès que la phase aiguë la présence
américaine en afghanistan c'est terminé
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit ils sont
adressés monde entier y compris la
russie obéit aux républiques d'asie
centrale donne un ordre joly donné ordre
à l'union européenne
tous les réfugiés
tous les fuyards d'afghanistan
accueillez les nous en avons parlé alors
lors de la conférence en ligne ok ce
problème nous sommes
parvenus opinion
unique les repas ont répondu présent à
l'appel et au fait chez eux venir c'est
à venir chez eux vous souhaitez si vous
les avez appelé venir chez vous
voulez les écueils iso travailler pour
vous pendant ces années il y a des
centaines de milliers d'afghans qui
pendant vingt ans on travaillait pour
ceux qui les abandonnent pour rentrer
sains dans leur tanière
que vous le demandez vous à moi roubaix
le russe est d'autant plus fort à la
russie mais il faut bien comprendre
que certains afghans irakiens séparé
avec l'irak iso détruit s'épanouit ni de
la russie ils
fuient le libor et d'autres pays par là
aussi la meinau reçu directement belle
russie cela concerne la russie d'un mais
de aussi dira t'on c'est pas nous qui
les avons appelés c'est pendant qu'ils
cherchent ils veulent aller ailleurs là
où on les appelait venir
accueillir votre
proposition qu'est ce que je demande que
vous nous demandent que vendée nous mais
vous êtes en train de nous accabler de
vos sanctions tous les gens que tu
fasses pour les socios nous avons déjà
devancé la fédération de russie tant de
sanctions quoi je dois ou le peuple veut
lui aussi doit les protéger à la
frontière non
ils ont
terminé ils ont annulé tous les
programmes
ce sont des fruits de notre politique
regardent leurs visages vais pas parler
brutalement je vous le dire
regardez les démocratiquement ils tirent
ils auront déchirure des chiens
policiers pologne en les capturant
lituanien pologne format groupe il les
chasse par la frontière vers nous en
tirant par dessus les têtes pour le voir
même il ya eu des morts
qui se bat qui logeaient des cadavres
prenez vos cadeaux
voilà c'est ça leur visage démocratique
donc je ne vois pas ici de prétexte
de motifs pour au nous vouloir nous
demandant quelque chose dont nous sommes
acquis de notre mission en toute beauté
avant qu'il ne lui est bouleversée
laisse pas la force la situation dans le
pays pour abattre le pouvoir dans notre
pays légal légitime légale c'est le
peuple bélarusse qui viendra nous
n'avons pas à intervenir dans les
élections à merkel lorsque pas dans les
élections ils ont tiré à bout portant
sur des sommes trouvés d'abord fait de
leurs rochers vous d'abord balayer
devant votre porte selon faire qu'au
partenaire sûr si l'europe envies des
relations normales nous sont prêtes ne
se bien disposés à s'entendre avec
l'euro devant drôle le soutien de la
russie que nous les aurons besoin nous
allons agir ensemble pour le monde sait
pas ne se sert pas encore dieu merci pas
encore quand il le faudra nous allons
nous regrouper
nous unit rapidement pour lutter contre
tout cela dans l'intérêt des russes des
bd russe
alors pas mal ça robin va chevet cette
conférence
alors question deux dirigeants vous avez
annoncé beaucoup de nouveautés sur les
programmes
et la création de l'état de l'union se
fait depuis plus de 20 ans et la plupart
des décisions donc pas et est
aujourd'hui mise en oeuvre si on parle
des décisions d'aujourd'hui à quel point
à quelle étape du parcours se trouve
aujourd'hui la russie et la biélorussie
et à quel point elles se sont
rapprochées de l'exécution des décisions
qui avaient été prises il ya vingt ans
je considère que
c'est par sa qu'il fallait commencer
depuis longtemps
ce dont nous avons parlé aujourd'hui jeu
sur quoi nous nous sommes mis d'accord
c'est à dire le fondement de nos
relations tout le reste ce n'est qu'une
super structure politique
et par conséquent
nous allons faire ce dont nous avons
convenu aujourd'hui à ce moment-là nous
pour mieux travailler pour les étapes se
vanter mais tout ça c'est l'avenir on va
voir comment la situation évolue elle
évolue rapidement
en tout cas
après l'exécution de programmes fixés à
ce moment là on pourra voir et je suis
convaincu que nous sommes sur la bonne
voie je soutiens complètement le chef de
l'état russe
j'ai pas de réponse particulière à votre
question si vous voulez entrer en détail
sur les d'accord sur les accords de
l'époque
si on peut
chercher la petite bête oui c'est
possible nous sommes toujours prêts à
revenir et on peut revenir sur ces
crises sur ces accords de l'époque mais
comme l'a dit le président
et c'est important nous avons créé une
base et on ne se trompe pas et on va
partir de cette date et je pourrais vous
en parler en détail
et avec le président russe ne pouvons en
parler pendant deux heures pendant trois
heures mais aujourd'hui regardez l'union
européenne ce qui se passe il ya
beaucoup de tendances aujourd'hui qui
mène plutôt à la désintégration et les
critiques se font ouverte aujourd'hui
mais ne nous voulons pas recommencer les
erreurs qui ont été faites dans le nom
soviétique nous ne voulons pas les
recommencer dans l'état de l'union
aujourd'hui il ya peut-être des choses
que nous avons
laissez passer mais nous sommes revenus
à la création d'une base une basse en
laquelle on n'y a pas de fondement pour
créer cet état d'intégration
et nous avons renoncé à faire ce qui est
superflu depuis longtemps je vous
remercie